well I'm honored to be lightning-bolt
number one my name is Jonathan runing
Shearer I teach statistics here at Yale
and I'm going to give it a quick sort of
discussion about the way to use video
capture sort of that's built into canvas
so the programming to talk about is
called Panopto I'm not a Panopto expert
nor do I get paid by them to tell this
so you know just ask and I'll tell you
straight up what my experience is if you
go to pan tapas website what they'll
tell you is that it's the easiest way to
manage livestream record and share
videos across your organization and so
the deal is the text is sort of part
Hardware part software part web-based
interface and so there are a number of
classrooms around here at Yale now that
have basically a permanent built-in
camera and in addition to the built-in
camera there's like this box which is
basically like a computer with a big
hard drive and the computer with a big
hard drive is then tied in not only to
the camera but also to whatever is being
presented in the classroom so
essentially it's a box that will capture
what the camera whatever mic you're
wearing in the classroom and whatever's
going up on the screens it sort of
automatically captures all of those
things now it's also software that you
don't have to have on your computer I do
on mine which means you can also use it
to do a quick video capture of yourself
just through your own kind of camera so
if you want it to respond to questions
that students posed online or like I got
to be in class you didn't get this today
here's three minutes of sort of response
very easy then to upload on to canvas
and so it's also then a web-based
interface which is part of what I really
like it's built into canvas which is
it's a great way to sort of grab the
videos automatically from those
specialized classrooms or you can upload
your own videos that you make yourself I
often use a program called Camtasia
which is frankly a great sort of video
editing software program that I use for
making sort of high-quality content
videos that I use but Panopto is a great
way to sort of organize those it's also
a great way just to sort of watch the
videos so it's also the interface that
students use to actually sort of
experience we do capture I'd say it's
also John Harford he's not here like
find them because he's he is the dude
walking right out there he was one of
our local Panopto experts and he's been
awesome person to helping me integrate
this so I sort of used Panopto video
capture in three classes over the last
12 months one of them is a huge class
about 250 students stat 10x it's
basically intro stats for mostly
undergrads I also have then a flipped
version of intro stats which is mostly
grad students with a few undergrads this
particular class actually I used that
program Camtasia to make fifty sort of
high quality content videos that
students watch before class and then the
class time is used to sort of run
examples and answer questions then also
this semester I'm teaching multivariate
statistics this is an upper-level
advanced class for grad students there's
about 110 of them and in this class it's
also a sort of a live class
so both the huge class and then this
multivariate class are classes I teach
live I stand up I give a lecture
students show up the usual time but the
camera also pops on automatically for
each class and so there's a video
capture of the lecture as well so so
what I used in the sort of stat 10x
class and multivariate so I captured the
videos they showed up automatically one
of the things that's great about the
integration of Panopto into canvas is
that literally in week one I spent
twenty minutes and pre-programmed every
time that the camera needed to show up
or turn on in a particular classroom and
that was the last I thought about it so
otherwise I just show up to class I plug
in my laptop as I always do and the
recording happens automatically it does
it streams live it's about a 40 second
delay as what I discovered right here
they're trying to get it down to 20 or
so but it also then automatically
records it and so the students then can
go on after the fact and and watch
videos for my intro class Panopto is
also just good as a video organizational
tool so as I said I've sort of produced
these content videos for the flipped
version but after a couple years I was
like that everyone who's in the intro
class might as well have access to those
if they like them so it's also a great
way just to kind of organize what the
videos sort of look like so this is more
about how do I tend to teach so my
experience with interest stats is I'm
trying to create a multitude of ways
that people can learn sort of a stature
morges board and so there are any class
I teach there's like a thousand slides
big font like you know there's like that
size so they can use those I release
them in four batches so they're always
kind of three weeks ahead if they want
to read ahead there is they can come to
class we're all lecture as I would
usually and I'm happy to answer their
questions there's the video capture what
happens live and then for the intro
classes there's this kind of topic topic
videos so the deal is students can
decide to come to class if they want but
they don't
have to sew if they'd rather just stay
home in their PJs and watch the videos
that is totally fine with me or they can
watch the PDF file or they can do any
combination of those things my
experience is that students do all of
those so they you know some of them have
a particular modality they like many of
them use more than one depending on
what's going on in their lives and also
the topic that we're sort of discussing
so for those of you who might be
thinking like Casas my video capture my
class no one will ever show up again but
so that was certainly you know I thought
what if I show up and there's just me in
the video camera so what I discovered is
that in the large intro class only about
25% of students decided to exclusively
watch the videos so they just stayed at
home and that was the only way they
wanted to use the information it's been
a larger percentage in the multivariate
class about 35 to 40 percent of students
decide to stay at home but it's
interesting even of the people who show
up in class every semester I'll say a
quick show of hands who's watched a
video at least once now students don't
like to raise their hand under any
circumstance and still 95 percent of
hands go up and say we used it at least
once
here are the reasons that they talked
about for wanting to use the videos they
had another class the same time they had
to miss for illness etc or they might
just use the video to review other
topics so what I want to do now is just
sort of show you what this looks like so
if you are in canvas the ways that this
sort of looks here is that there's
something called media library here and
so all the videos that I recorded they
just show up like that
and so to watch a video then this is
sort of what it actually looks like if
you actually are sort of watching a
video so students then if they're if
they're watching a video they get the
screen capture over here or if they want
to watch me I don't know who would want
to but they can watch me there as well
the audio was good as long as you have a
good good mic on as well if you're using
Camtasia to sort of organize your videos
right here under create you can see the
different ways that you can sort of make
a recording inside of canvas so what if
you want to sort of pre record you just
go to the sort of scheduled recording
but I've also used it to sort of upload
pre done videos anyway quick smooth now
shut up you can ask question
what do you got yes another nice thing
about this business you can annotate
time time codes
yeah never say risk wake up pay
attention here or this is the example I
did in class or whatever and the
students can also send questions based
on time good yeah which is cool and
partly like because I have this kind of
like these slides as well they can
always just sort of slide along here and
see what you know what's the slide
number they're on so a lot of them will
have a hard copy in front of them even
as they're watching the videos to kind
of make noise like other questions yes
right so you can talk to John Harper
he'll tell you all about it but
literally the way it works I'll show you
if I were to go and schedule a recording
quickly here it says I'm going to go
schedule a recording and what they had
do is for they know where I teach
they've given me access to a couple of
rooms and so I just say in this room at
this time on these days turn on that's
how it works other questions
yes I do
it has not the particular groups that I
teach after a class or two they learn
I'm pretty low-key and they ask
questions no matter what I don't and I
don't and the camera certainly isn't
looking at them and in some ways the
questions act one thing you have to have
to learn was the questions don't the mic
doesn't pick them up so if they say
something that I really I'll be
embarrassed for them I don't repeat what
they said and no one will ever know but
I tell them on day one you will be
recorded in this class and you can use
this class however you want but I didn't
hear anybody saying I don't feel
comfortable being recorded here it
didn't hesitate yes student performance
for that 25 or that forty percent I
don't have enough data to say anything
relevant about that but what I would say
is the lastly last last thing I know I'm
outside I'm going to show you is that
for any particular video you can go get
rid of all the stats for that particular
video and part of what's interesting is
to sort of see just the distribution of
who watches it when so for this one here
I'm just going to sort of set it so it
goes over the person in the counter
there's nobody it's there it's canvas
automatically sort of link to them in so
it's like sort of set up automatic
anyway what you can do here is that I
can actually it's not impose a whole it
but I can see exactly when who watch the
video when the video went up here so
these are the people who got right on
and watched these are the people waited
until there was a homework assignment on
that particularly thing and these are
the people wanted to review because they
needed it for their final project and if
you look at sort of usage by individual
you can see there are some people who
they're just learners they need extra
time and so they'll watch it two or
three times then there's the people who
sit down and then watch it once at a
stretch but there's also plenty of
people who like they come like they want
ten minutes at a time and so that's the
way they learn or that's the way that
they get interrupted and then there are
people who sort of spot-check down here
like I didn't get it in class so I'm
going to come back and just look at that
particular part later okay yeah
[Music]